لم تشعر سيرا أرزو أبدًا أنها بحاجة إلى
مسدس
حتى الآن ،
وهي أم وحيدة لثلاثة أطفال ، اشترت حدادًا
ويسون وتعلمت كيفية
التصوير
لأن العالم الذي عرفته قد تغير ،
أشعر
أنني أشعر بالخوف حقًا من
الذخيرة جاءت من
بعد أن حصلت أرجو على مسدسها
اشترت صديقته واحدة
أيضًا ولم تتوقف عند هذا الحد ، ثم
صديقي الجامعي الذي طلبته
أن يأتي معي لشراء البندقية لأنني
كنت متوترًا لشراء البندقية ،
حصلت بالفعل على بندقيته الأسبوع الماضي ، لذا فأنت
مرحبًا بك.
تُظهر بيانات الصناعة أن الأمريكيين قاموا
بتسليح أنفسهم في عام 2020 بأرقام قياسية
قاموا بشراء 23 مليون سلاح
ناري في يناير
في ميشيغان.
من الوباء ،
ثم جاءت مظاهرة صيفية أعقبتها
اضطرابات سياسية ،
فكان نوعًا من العاصفة المثالية من حيث
الطلب
على الأسلحة النارية في نطاق ستودارد
والبنادق في أتلانتا تي.  لم تتغير البنادق
كثيرًا
ولكن العملاء رأينا الكثير من
النساء يأتون
إلى الكثير من الأزواج الذين لديهم أطفال ،
ونحن نرى حقًا كل
مناحي الحياة فيليب سميث من
الاتحاد الأفريقي الأمريكي للأسلحة النارية
يقول إنهم  عند رؤية حوالي ألف عضو جديد
شهريًا ، هل ترى الكثير من مشتري الأسلحة لأول مرة ،
أقول إن حوالي 70 بالمائة من الأشخاص الذين
يمشون عبر الباب من أجل ناجا
يتم إجراؤهم لأول مرة بواسطة أصحاب الأسلحة لأول مرة
خبراء طبيون أظهروا
الأبحاث التي تظهر النمو الهائل
سيؤدي بيع الأسلحة النارية إلى حدوث
نوع آخر من الأزمات الصحية ، وهو ارتفاع في
جرائم القتل
والانتحار والإصابات الخطيرة ، ونحن نعلم أن
معظم هذه الإصابات غير المقصودة
تحدث لأفراد الأسرة أو الأطفال ،
لذا فإن امتلاك سلاح في الواقع يعد أمرًا خطيرًا
في حد ذاته
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالنفس  -حماية إيفان
تقول إن أقنعة الوجه
وغسل اليدين سيكونان أكثر أمانًا
وفعالية عند العودة إلى النطاق الذي
تقوله سييرا أرزو عندما لا
تمارسها ، فإنها تبقي مسدسها الجديد
مغلقًا على
أمل أن  إنه لا يحتاجها أبدًا ولكنه يشعر
بالراحة مع العلم أنها موجودة
في أوقات غير مؤكدة ، ولا أعلم
أنها مثل بطانية الأمان
كما تعلم مارتن سافاج سي إن أتلانتا